[Musica]
parlare di regia cinematografica
per me vuol dire
affrontare molte onde emotive emozionali
devo dire che al regista come persona
come figura professionale vengono poste
sempre molte domande soprattutto sul set
sono domande difficili a volte sono
domande solo tecniche dove posizionare
la camera come gestire una cosa con
l'attore con un'attrice eccetera
però spesso ai registi non vengono fatte
delle domande importanti
ad esempio a me piacerebbe molto se
qualcuno mi chiedesse cosa resterà del
tuo sguardo ad esempio ma soprattutto mi
piacerebbe pensare è una cosa su cui
rifletto molto anche quando sono in aula
su cosa c'è dietro uno sguardo per cui
oggi in realtà non farò non volevo fare
lo sanno benissimo le amiche e gli amici
del teteks un ragionamento sul senso
della regia
perché chi è il regista più o meno
credo sia cosa nota volevo cercare di
sondare un po quello che è l'abisso del
regista quando crea un film e parlare
del regista creatore vuol dire
innanzitutto interrogarsi sul senso di
quello che lo muove che è una materia
oscura che è la materia dell'ispirazione
che è qualcosa che non ha possibilità di
essere
interrogata che non ha una risposta
probabilmente quindi i minuti
trascorreranno senza soluzioni forse
solo con alcune suggestioni
però io credo fortemente nel fatto che
quello che è il senso del fare cinema e
questo
distingue registi che riprendono dai
registri che filmano che c'è una bella
differenza
sia quella di capire cosa in un modo o
nell'altro li spinge a rischiare perché
ogni film è un'operazione
destabilizzante lo è perché girare un
film vuol dire innanzitutto esporsi
spogliarsi mettersi in gioco mostrare
dei punti fragili delle debolezze così
come anche rischiare il non gradimento
perché fare un film comunque
inevitabilmente un atto di comunità
allora per cercare di capire
come iniziare a parlare di ispirazione
ho cercato è un riferimento a cui
ritorno spesso soprattutto in alcuni
momenti di riflessione solitaria
un'immagine non ho uno slide non o
supporti se non questa immagine ed è
un'immagine che la faccio partire con
questo pulsante perfetto che racconta
una storia
questa storia a cui sono molto
affezionato ma così esternamente senza
ragione e comincia in un
ristorante in una giornata molto fredda
a mosca nel 1916
qui c'è una ragazza che a quasi 18 anni
che si chiama nina andrea scaglia che è
all tavolo con alcuni suoi amici
verranno della vodka mangeranno zuppe
calde per riscaldarsi da un'ennesima
giornata fredda
succede all'improvviso allora non
esistevano i cellulari
che annina andrea sky a viene chiesto di
consegnare un messaggio telefonicamente
al pittore vasilij kandinskij che nel
1916 invece di anni ne ha quasi 50 e
così accade questa cosa per cui mina
chiama vasili e recapita questo
messaggio da parte di questi amici il
pittore dall'altra parte nei diari dei
suoi racconti dal dolo esprime molto
bene con grande suggestione rimane
colpito dal forte impatto che questa
voce
nelle sue emozioni nelle sue corde più
interiori e così quando la telefonata
finisce in comincia a dipingere la voce
quello che vedete è un primo piano in
verità anche se nessuno lo sa perché
questo è il volto che
vasilij kandinskij ha immaginato per
nina andrea scaglia è un primo piano
quelle che vedete come delle schegge
sono degli occhi io mi immagino
quest'uomo che incomincia ad avere
dentro la testa cicogne e minareti in
con qualche modo come tutti gli artisti
creativi e che decide di cominciare a
dare schizzi al colore per riuscire a
visualizzarle allora questa storia poi
ovviamente la storia ha un lieto fine
nel senso che lui farà arrivare questa
tela a nina nei due si sposeranno
trascorrendo molti anni nella loro vita
assieme però perché cito questa storia
mentre il tempo inesorabile continua a
ricordarmi delle che passa per che
l'ispirazione un po così questa tela si
chiama alla voce sconosciuta
e allora a me piace credere anzi io sono
fortemente convinto di questo che
l'ispirazione sia un po una voce
sconosciuta
qualcosa che ci manipola c manovra ci
rende fair per fortuna non razionali non
logici disordinati caotici esattamente
come come questo primo piano
apparentemente ma soprattutto ha in sé
uno degli elementi che dal mio punto di
vista è centrale nella definizione
dell'ispirazione dell'essere artista o
dell'essere creativo se non ambiamo a
essere artisti cioè che è lo sconosciuto
e l'ignoto la voce sconosciuta un po
quella come quella dei degli aerei o dei
cantori no che cercavano nelle muse
quando dovevano cominciare le loro opere
qualcosa che aiutasse intervenisse a
dare loro come dire una scossa
emozionale aspettavano anche loro delle
voci sconosciute così se dovessi dire
cosa muove almeno dal mio modesto punto
di vista l'ispirazione io direi
innanzitutto l'ignoto cioè io tento
continuamente a dimenticare di conoscere
a dimenticare perché noi abbiamo sempre
questo continuo obbligo di ricordare
addirittura i social ci ricordano questa
foto è stata postata a tre anni fa due
anni fa invece il beneficio dell'uomo
sarebbe dimenticare perché dimenticare
tifa esplorare quello che hai conosciuto
hai dimenticato di conoscere molto più
interessante da un punto di vista della
rep presentazione lo sconosciuto però
per essere
fecondato per essere nutrito ha bisogno
di alcune leggi se non codici che
convivono nella vita quotidiana di ogni
persona e che spesso ci creano conflitti
con le persone però se voi pensate bene
la prima cosa per cui noi ci
appassioniamo ha un'idea un'entità è
qualcosa che non ci appartiene
e lo sconosciuto vive dove non vive
l'abitudine ad esempio perché lo
sconosciuto è imprevedibile
lo sconosciuto abita dove non c'è la
convenienza perché dove c'è la
convenienza noi siamo agiati e non
abbiamo nessun motivo di essere scossi
come è stato scosso il nostro amico
vasili ma soprattutto mi viene da
pensare
così come è la voce sconosciuta
l'ispirazione che forse l'ispirazione
nasce da ciò che ci manca per questo è
una tela particolarmente rappresentativa
per me perché lui non ha un'immagine lui
ha solo un timbro ed è un timbro che lo
condiziona due mozioni allora per me
essere ispirato vuol dire
avvicinarsi a quello che mi manca anche
adesso mentre nuovo le mie labbra e
penso a qualcosa quello che mi ispira
non è presente in questa sala
ad esempio una persona
un'idea un sentimento non c'è tutto
questo per ricordare che
fare i film non è un atto non è un
obbligo non è un vincolo è un'esplosione
e allora sempre se dovessi dare delle
ricette cosa molto complicata sul tema
dell'ispirazione uno degli altri
elementi che io ci terrei al di là di
quelli che ho appena riferito è
senz'altro il piccolo c'è una frase
molto bella dalle signore delle camelie
no che è un'opera che io amo molto che
dice che nel piccolo c'è tutto così come
nell'uomo così come nel bambino c'è
l'uomo
così come nell'occhio abita l'universo
sarà segnalata ed è così
probabilmente è una mia suggestione però
io sono uno di quelli che si emoziona
ancora sarò patemi co
però quando vedo un ombrello rotto per
terra con queste gambe divaricate una
giornata di pioggia penso alla storia di
quell'ombrello a kg apparteneva perché
l'ha lasciato lì ho così sono facilmente
condizionabile da tutti quegli elementi
superflui rilevanti inutili forse che
cascano nelle nostre giornate dove
corriamo talmente tanto che poi basta
davvero capire e vedere come è possibile
l'altro giorno che entro una farfallina
metropolitana che non capisco ancora
come diavolo ci sia entrata e
soprattutto come sia ancora lì a battere
le ali
allora questo tutto questo riporta il
tema su una cosa che non ha possibilità
di essere discussa forse un teteks però
io non voglio parlare del regista come
colui che è una persona che deve avere
del metodo certo il regista dell'avere
metodo di una persona che deve essere
organizzata certo assolutamente una
persona che deve avere una strategia
comunicativa assolutamente tutte queste
cose sono cose che a voi sono note e
probabilmente sono cose ripetute oggi
volevo provare in questo spazio
dei drammatici 18 minuti che poi in
verità sono 16 nel cerchio rosso di
questo pianeta in cui mi sto muovendo
non sapete la voglia che ho di andare lì
ma poi bisogna rifare tutto quindi un
dramma non lo posso fare sono ancora con
questo cosa lo posso appoggiare se non
devono averlo più oppure lo appoggia io
non sono abituato a tenere i microfoni
sono abituato a vagabondare quando parlo
quindi questa è una cosa drammatica
dicevo il tema del dell'ispirazione e
quella che secondo me avvicina anche le
persone da un punto di vista di chi non
vuole fare regia perché questo in fondo
se lo vogliamo decifrare o parafrasare o
interpretare non è un ragionamento che
vale solo per i registi anch'io oggi sto
andando a fare la spesa perché voglio
preparare un dolce alla persona che amo
cosa mi ispira oppure semplicemente sono
in treno vedo il paesaggio che scorre
dal finestrino e sono ispirato da una
cosa che vedo per caso e questa cosa mi
fa mandare un messaggio alla persona a
cui voglio dichiararmi l'ispirazione è
totale per quello non è del regista però
il regista è un essere una bellissima
frase di simon de beauvoir è un'autrice
chiamo molto che dice bisogna che
bisogna accettare l'avventura di essere
se stessi no
è nei confronti dei registi o forse
delle persone che hanno anche delle
tentazioni o delle tendenze creative che
sono fortemente destabilizzanti perché
davvero uno a volte vorrebbe essere
tranquillo invece c'è sempre una molla
personale sentimentale artistica
reputazionale che ti deve mettere in
gioco perché non può esaurire
continuamente la voglia di raccontare e
sai che raccontare però ti spinge
continuamente avvenuta arti e tutto
questo è una continua catena di
inquietudine allora dentro tutto questo
sistema fallace bisogna raccogliere
l'avventura di essere noi stessi
probabilmente
io cito sempre cose perché ogni tanto
anche ieri mentre correggevo le tesi di
alcune studentesse di alcuni studenti
vedo vedo delle cose che mi ispirano
c'è una frase di un altro poeta
eccezionale che un poeta siriano nisar
cavani non è molto noto però magari lo
potete vedere segnare che dice la luce è
più importante della lanterna
così come la poesia è più importante del
taccuino allora mi verrebbe da dire un
po in chiusura visto che i secondi vanno
contro di me che l'ispirazione è più
importante del cinema o forse del fare
film questa è una cosa che provo anche
in qualche modo a trasmettere quando
sono dietro una cattedra e o questa
pesante responsabilità di insegnare una
materia che non è una materia per cui
sono sempre lì a raccontare cose mentre
qualcuno dall'altra parte sogna di
viverle e allora capisci che non ci sono
algoritmi e lavagne e bacchette e
telecomandi in cui poi disporre tutto
secondo delle formule organizzate perché
il cinema è totalmente il disordine no
purtroppo c'è un problema ci sono molte
persone che fanno film ma poche persone
che fanno cinema però ecco
in qualche modo l'ispirazione è più
importante perché se non c'è
l'ispirazione quindi non c'è una ragione
mi viene da pensare perché noi dobbiamo
raccontare perché noi dobbiamo anche
soffrire
a volte lo dico come un'esperienza ma è
giusto condividerla a volte noi ci
procuriamo quell'assenza è un paradosso
noi per riuscire ad avere
quell'ispirazione dobbiamo procurarci la
voce sconosciuta che coincide con
qualcosa che non abbiamo perché se
abbiamo qualcosa
caschiamo smentiamo noi stessi forse ci
paralizzano probabilmente all'ora detto
tutto questo che non so se come flusso
di coscienza perché come avevo avvertito
io non preparo degli speech da mandare
in anticipo per perché non mi appartiene
questa formulazione volevo vivere il
momento di questa sala dove ricordo con
affetto è stata la prima sala dove sono
venuto a vedere un film a milano e
quindi e c'è anche questa ordine
simbolico che ritorna
chiudo dicendo che forse l'ispirazione
un segreto che ognuno di noi ha nel
senso che come si fa a parlare di un
segreto segreti sono fatti per non
essere detti però è anche vero
amiche e amici che le immagini come dice
qualcuno sono segreti di un segreto e
che più dicono meno mostrano in qualche
modo
e allora se qualcosa può essere utile di
queste parole se qualcosa può servire a
chi ascolta chi è distratto chi
semplicemente voleva venire questa
mattina per raccogliere un'ispirazione
forse la cosa migliore è non parlare di
ispirazione e coltivare il segreto
grazie
[Applauso]